oh it sounds like a new president
you know every time
good afternoon welcome come on up here
Leo good afternoon it's great to see all
of you here uh and today I am thrilled
to have someone else making their
briefing room debut we have the director
of the National Economic Council Lil
Brainerd here with us at the podium for
the first time Leo as many of you may
already know brings a tremendous amount
of experience to the president's
economic team having previously served
as a vice chair of the Federal Reserve
under secretary at the U.S treasury and
a deputy director of the NEC Leo has
been a tremendous asset to our team as
we've navigated the past few months and
today she's here to talk with you about
bidenomics which is the word of the day
word of the week word of the month word
of the Year here at the White House and
bidenomics is rooted in the belief that
we grow the economy when we grow the
middle class so Leo with that I will
turn it over to you for a few remarks
well thank you very much and good
afternoon
as you know the president's traveling to
Chicago tomorrow to deliver a major
address on the U.S economy when the
president came to office the economy was
reeling and Supply chains had broken
down
but instead of going for a short-term
fix the president recognized that many
of the challenges in our economy
had been developing over a longer period
of time
he rejected trickle-down economics the
theory that tax cuts at the top would
trickle down
that all we needed was for government to
get out of the way that failed approach
led to a pullback of private investment
from Key Industries like semiconductors
to solar it led to a deterioration of
the nation's infrastructure and it led
to a loss of a path to middle class for
too many Americans in too many
communities around the country
so the president vowed to put in place a
very different approach
a approach that grows the economy from
the middle out and the bottom up
and that is very focused on growing our
middle class
the president will outline the three key
areas that are at the heart of that
strategy
first we're making smart investments in
America in sectors that are critical to
our economic and National Security
focusing on infrastructure clean energy
and semiconductors and doing it in a way
that catalyzes more private investment
not less the president's historic
legislation has already catalyzed about
500 billion in private sector
commitments
I think it is on this chart that you can
see we've seen a boom in private sector
spending on manufacturing construction
since the president's investment agenda
was enacted
and we're doing it in partnership with
friends and allies around the world and
we're doing it in a way that achieves
our climate goals secondly the president
has prioritized policies to empower and
educate American workers the president
will highlight the historic labor market
recovery and what it's meant for workers
and families that were too often left
behind in previous recoveries he'll talk
about the steps that his administration
is taking to educate and Empower
American workers with a focus on
developing skills for the jobs
of the future including those that don't
require four years of college by
supporting unionization and creating
apprenticeships among other steps and
finally the president is going to talk
about the importance of promoting
competition both to lower costs and to
provide a Level Playing Field for small
businesses by doing things like getting
rid of non-compete clauses bringing down
costs from insulin to hearing aids and
focusing on junk fees and he'll note all
the ways that his plan is working since
the president has taken office
13 million jobs have been created the
unemployment rate is near historic lows
below 4 percent for the longest stretch
in nearly 50 years and we've received
record low unemployment for groups that
too frequently have been left behind
the share of working age Americans in
the workforce is higher now than it has
been for 15 years showing that decisive
policy in a strong economy can bring
more people into the workforce and you
can see that here
real incomes are up especially for lower
income workers
small business applications are at
record high
and today while we have more work to do
inflation's been coming down for 11
months in a row so with that let me wrap
up and I'll take a few questions
thanks so much so in the memo that the
White House released he pointed to a
stronger economic recovery from the
pandemic compared to other major
economies lots of good jobs putting the
middle class in a better position than
it was pre-pandemic but which of the
policies the president's policy
specifically led to those outcomes
so I think think the sum total of the
president's policies uh the four
historic pieces of legislation that he's
passed along with a slew of
administrative actions together are
leading to investments in industries of
the future they're leading to great new
job opportunities and we see those in
places like Weirton West Virginia where
we're seeing an iron ear battery plant
opening on the site of an Old Mill that
when it shut down lost jobs in that area
and of course we're also seeing it in
the steps that are being taken to
increase competition and to create
better opportunities for small
businesses so it's really the sum total
of all three prongs of his policies that
are working to create a strong economy
but also an economy that will be
resilient for the long term because
we're investing in infrastructure and
just yesterday day as you know the
president announced over 40 billion in
investments in high-speed internet as
part of an overall program over two
different laws that is going to lead to
every household in America having access
to high-speed internet which is very
similar to the approach that we saw in
the rural electrification act undertaken
by Franklin Delano Roosevelt
Andrea yeah I thank you for being here I
wanted to ask you about this boom in
construction manufacturing
um and whether you think that in
combination with the new housing starts
that we saw were the numbers also went
up in May will lead to some relief on
the housing price issue that could help
with inflation and then I I want to ask
you about the overall outlook for the
economy whether
um you're more confident now that there
will be a self-planning and that a
recession can be ordered yeah so I think
it is going to be important
um over a medium term of several years
to see greater housing Supply
and that will help to provide uh longer
term Solutions but even in the short run
if you look at the data on rent for
instance
the average rent is projected to come
down for Americans over the second half
of this year providing really important
relief to a lot of American
families what was the second part of
your question can a recession be avoided
so in terms of yeah where we are on the
economy what has been interesting is you
know there have been these repeated
predictions and yet what we've seen in
the actual data has been a lot of
resilience so again we're continuing to
see strong labor market low unemployment
we've actually seen that stretch of a
strong labor market
um
improved due to the very large increase
we've seen in participation of working
age Americans and so there are reasons
to think that we are going to continue
to see resilience against a backdrop of
what we have referred to as more stable
economic growth
Kelly
thanks for being here when you look at
the overall picture
um with respect to office space in
cities and how that has been an issue
with the changing way people work do you
see that as having
um an impact on the economy if those
buildings you know can't be the same to
sustain the companies and the banks that
are involved there and uh
with the kinds of projections you're
doing for the infrastructure building
and the broadband and all of that when
we have such a tight labor market where
do you foresee uh that pool of workers
to be and can it be satisfied yeah so in
terms of commercial real estate this is
obviously an area that we've been uh
tracking closely within commercial real
estate it's really that segment that you
refer to
um it's office space only some of the
other areas of commercial real estate
have actually been doing quite well like
industrial and even retail has been
doing better multi-family has been doing
very well but yes uh some areas office
is now adjusting to different patterns
of working or remote work potentially so
that needs to work its way through and
of course we're very attentive to where
those financial risks May lie and so far
they seem to be being managed pretty
well but we're going to stay focused on
that and the second piece was matching
workers with jobs so the president's
agenda includes a lot of initiatives
that are intended precisely to make sure
that our Workforce in the places where
we're seeing those Investments is
skilled and is connected to those jobs
and so we talk about registered
apprenticeships the president just
traveled to North Carolina to
participate in meetings at a community
college that was part of a Consortium
that resulted from his legislation and
those those students are being connected
directly to these jobs associated with
investments in our manufacturing sector
and in some cases going back to high
school level curricula and that's very
much what he has in mind when he talks
about how skilled the workers that are
involved in some of these
very complicated
industries of the future are and the
pathway that might include
apprenticeships might include Community
College but need not include a four-year
College
thank you so you're in the briefing room
today thank you very much
yes please come back anytime
so I just have one piece of brief news
at the top before we get to questions
um today the Biden Harris Administration
is announcing a new security assistance
package for Ukraine as we continue to
stand with the people of Ukraine as they
defend themselves from Russia's brutal
invasion this package includes key
capabilities that will support Ukraine's
counter-offensive operations such as
mine clearing equipment armored vehicles
and artillery rounds
it will also strengthen air defenses to
help Ukraine protect its people from
rocket attacks and provide Ukraine with
additional anti-armor systems and
ammunition for the high Mars rocket
systems that Ukraine has is using so
effectively on the battlefield
this is the 41st drawdown of equipment
from the dod inventories using
presidential drawdown authorities for
Ukraine that Congress approved last year
with strong bipartisan support and as
President Biden told president zielinski
on Sunday we continue to support Ukraine
as it defends its sovereignty and
territorial Integrity from Russian
aggression
segment
first time
um so two questions can you offer more
details about the lunch with uh
President Obama and President Biden
today is it just kind of a fun check-in
thing or do they have a specific agenda
um I think President Obama has been
doing a lot on the issue of democracy is
that something that they're going to
touch on during
well as you know the two leaders the two
presidents stay in touch regularly they
most recently spoke in early June when
President Obama called President Biden
to congratulate him on reaching the
bipartisan budget agreement which I
believe we read out to you all the time
and certainly they've seen each other
regularly in the months before that but
you know President Biden is happy to be
hosting President Obama here at the
white house this afternoon for lunch I'm
not going to detail there or speculate
on what their private conversations
might detail or it might involve but to
say that they always look forward to
seeing each other and having a chance to
sit down in person is it safe to say
it's more like a social meeting or
anything
agenda I wouldn't there's no specific
agenda to this meeting they meet
regularly this is part of that regular
Cadence of of meetings and I'm sure it
will continue
um and on the student loan decision that
we expect from the Supreme Court I mean
I know the Administration has said over
and over that you're confident you know
people link your legal argument before
the justices but
does that mean you have no plan B in
case this is struck down what is your
alternative
um if the justices don't rule the way
that you want to vote well look I think
what we've consistently said is that we
have been very confident in the legal
argument that the solicitor general uh
put before argued before The Supreme
Court and we're not going to get ahead
of what the Supreme Court's outcome is
here
um but let's also be clear about the
stakes the whole reason the president
pursued the student debt relief program
is because of what the importance of the
breathing room that this will provide
potentially to millions and millions of
Americans who just stated a little bit
more breathing room as we came out of
this pandemic and so while we won't get
ahead of the decision we know that the
stakes couldn't be higher for student
borrowers right now and certainly we're
watching along with the millions of
people who desperately need that student
debt relief to see what the court will
do here and
I was going to ask I'm director Brainerd
this um
while we're focused on the camps the
fate of the cancellation program
obviously the student loan payment the
repayments will resume again shortly and
I'm wondering if the Administration has
done any sort of research or if it has
any projections on what kind of a drag
that would be on consumer spending and
subsequently upon me well first of all
with respect to the the lifting of the
student loan cause the Department of
Education is going to be in touch
directly with student borrowers to make
sure that they have what they need and
the information that they need is that
prepares to resume but with respect to
the economy I would say part of the
reason that we did this is because you
know you heard uh lail just talk about
the idea of Dynamics the idea that we
grow the economy by growing the middle
class that we grow the economy by
empowering and educating workers by
giving low and you know growing from the
bottom up in the middle out here and
certainly the student debt relief
program fits into that idea the idea
that coming out of this pandemic once in
a generation pandemic the challenges
that student student borrowers faced as
a result
certainly the idea of giving folks a
little bit more breathing room to get
out from under mountains of student debt
so that they can you know do things like
start a small business or buy a home or
save for uh you know their their kids
college education these are the kinds of
things that we think will have a
significant impact and a benefit to the
economy over the long term
repayments when you're actually when
they have less money to spend I mean
does that concern the administration at
all about the impact again I'm not going
to get into hypotheticals about what the
potential outcome of the Supreme Court
decision might be what I will say is
that we feel that this is an incredibly
important program
for the the student borrowers across the
country who just need a little bit more
Breathing Room Mary
continues to show this pretty large
disconnect between the economic
successes that you all are touting and
highlighting this week and the way
Americans are actually feeling about the
economy the way they're feeling about
their own wallets you know inflation and
recession fears continue to be a pretty
big pull on the president's popularity
so
why do you think that is and is this big
Rebrand going to be enough to bridge
that divide and turn things around well
what I would say is that the president's
economic policies are incredibly popular
when you ask people what they think
about investing in our roads Bridges and
airports which you when you ask people
what they think about educating and
empowering workers when you ask people
about how they feel about restoring
manufacturing jobs and investing in
America those things are incredibly
popular and we find that when we go out
and we talk to people about it they
support biodynamics and so that's
exactly what the president is going to
be doing in Chicago tomorrow that's
exactly why we're we're talking to
Americans about everything that he's
doing to make sure that we grow the
economy by growing the middle class so
give people the the support that they
need to uh to grow our economy for us
and yet despite those numbers that you
just said I mean according to our last
poll 54 to 36 say Donald Trump did a
better job handling the economy when he
was president than Biden has done so far
you aren't announcing anything new
necessarily this week you are just you
know
highlighting and touting what you've
done is that enough well what I would
say to you is look at where we were when
we came into office when after four
years of Donald Trump unemployment was
over six percent and today we are
standing here at a time where
unemployment has is at historic lows
we've seen inflation come down for by 50
over the last year 11 months straight
inflation has come down we've recovered
our economy has recovered faster than
any major economy in the entire world
and that's happening because of
President Biden's leadership because of
the economic agenda that he's put
forward two and a half years into this
Administration we are just seeing this
the the first impacts of all the
historic legislation that he was able to
achieve in the first couple of years
we're seeing shovels and grounds we're
seeing
um we're seeing private investment come
back to our country we're seeing
millions of jobs created and so now is
the time where with all of those
accomplishments the president can take
this message to the American people and
say
this is what bidenomics is and here's
what we have to show for it let's put
our foot on the gas and keep moving
forward instead of returning to these
failed trickle-down policies that never
seem to ever trickle down on one other
topic United Airlines is calling out the
FAA for failing uh the traveling public
saying the faa's Staffing and
inexperience are crippling air travel
what's your response and are there any
steps you know emergency steps priority
steps that can be taken to manage some
of this chaos out there I think look
across the country over the last couple
of days we've seen some really severe
weather millions of people have been
impacted by that seen it up close I know
I know people who had multiple canceled
flight flights yesterday as a result of
the extreme weather weather that we're
seeing the people at the FAA the men
women of the FAA are always willing to
work collaboratively with companies to
solve the problem and I uh and I would
just say that I know that the FAA is
speaking to this and and stands ready to
work with companies to address any
issues they're facing
just come up here
um first on the economy you and this
White House continues to point out that
on individual issues that have been
passed and that are being implemented
they are popular with the American
public why does the White House think
consistently however that Americans
grade the president so poorly on his
handling of the economy well look I just
said that we're just starting to feel
the impact of the president's economic
agenda over the last couple of years I
mean we he in the span of two years time
passed bipartisan infrastructure law the
inflation reduction act chips and
science act and now we're starting to
see we are reaching the implementation
phase where people are seeing 35 000
infrastructure projects and shovels and
grounds across the country where we're
seeing 490 million billion dollars in
private sector investment coming back to
the United States and reshoring of
hundreds of thousands of manufacturing
jobs in cities that had been hollowed
out for Generations so people are just
starting to see the impact of of all of
the successes of the last couple of
years under This president's economic
agenda and now is when we're able to not
only talk about what the president's
agenda is but point to the result and
the fact that we have to keep our foot
on the gas as I said to keep ourselves
moving forward here some of
them said by this guy
that's why instead of the year
so what point does
are the American people going to see
this or are they just not paying
attention to what's being done are they
not being patient enough look I think
the people all across the United States
of America are starting to see shovels
and grounds in their communities they're
seeing the president announce as he did
on Monday a commitment to connecting the
entire country through broad high
quality affordable Broadband access
which is going to make a difference in
the lives of millions of people and so
uh you know as we get farther into
implementation people are going to
continue to feel that they're going to
continue to see see that and they're
going to continue to hear from this
President about how we're going to
continue to make progress for them real
quick on student loans though uh do you
have a
to those Americans who have those
student loans that are waiting for the
Forgiveness or have enjoyed the
Forgiveness or to those that are perhaps
opposed to the program at all
what would be your message
to those especially with with loans who
are waiting as anxiously as the White
House is for a decision that President
Biden has fought for you every step of
the way you know the student debt relief
plan he announced to give millions of
student borrowers who were buried under
mountains of debt a little bit more
Breathing Room coming out of this
pandemic and in the face of that we saw
Republican lawmakers in Congress and
special interests
try to defund this program we saw them
introduce legislation that the president
had to veto to try and get this program
and we saw them go all the way to the
highest court in the land to try to rip
away student debt relief for millions of
student borrowers who desperately needed
it and this President the doj solicitor
general went to the court and fought
hard to protect this program now we are
confident in the legal arguments that
we've made we certainly hope the Supreme
Court agrees because we know all too
well what the stakes are for millions of
students
FAA why hasn't the president nominated
someone to leave that agency
it seems as if the airlines are losing
somewhat in there in their ability to
manage these travel
look at you know as you know we have
fought to swiftly confirm an FAA nominee
I don't have any Personnel announcements
with to share with you today but we do
have capable leadership in place at the
FAA who are making sure that our our
skies remains safe for our Travelers in
the meantime and are doing the hard work
of making sure that we meet the needs of
consumers in this busy travel season
okay and was the president able to
listen to that tape of his predecessor
that was released yesterday talking
about classified documents and if you
have any particular reaction to it I'm
simply just not going to go here and
refer you to the doj on anything related
to add to this matter
Andrea yes I just want to ask you about
Russia and Wagner what actions in
as an Administration to hold Wagner
accountable for for their
um for what we just saw over the last
few weeks and are you starting to you
know to what extent are you concerned
about a destabilization of Russia and
the impact that that would have on the
global economy but also on the conflict
so with respect to your first question
we we have taken action against Wagner
the Wagner group in the past I'm not
going to forecast any future action
against Wagner or even speculate on what
the future might hold as you know we are
continuing to monitor this situation
closely and stay in close coordination
with allies and partners across the
globe you saw the president secretary of
Lincoln secretary Austin doing that
across the weekend into Monday and
certainly the president continues to be
briefed on this situation and is
monitoring it very closely
um
we don't have a perfect picture right
now of what is happening but we want to
continue to make one thing very very
clear and that is that we resolutely
Stand By and support Ukraine you just
heard me a moment ago announced yet
another drawdown for Ukraine to make
sure that they have what they need to
defend their territorial sovereignty and
integrity and
you know you saw the president speak to
president zielinski on Sunday to
reinforce that directly so we'll
continue to make that clear we're
continuing to watch the situation I'm
not going to have much more to say on on
this today unfortunately we just are in
a place of waiting and watching and
working with our partners to make sure
we have an accurate assessment of what's
going on and did I miss the second part
of your emotional I have another one
actually
um
um what you know we we've seen reports
of Janet Yellen will be going to China
next uh next week
um and I'm I'm wondering about what you
know your plans are your thinking is
about having the president speak with
the president she after the whole
desktop of the last uh
yeah whatever it is
so I don't have any uh travel to preview
for for secretary Yellen certainly would
refer you to treasury the treasury
Department to make any announcement of
that nature
um with respect to the president I also
don't have any call uh to preview I
think you
um you heard him the other day say he
hopes to speak to president XI in the
near term but beyond that I don't have
anything to to add on that front what I
would say is that as you heard secretary
blinken say during his travels in the
region and on upon his return we've
continued to feel it's really important
that we have multiple channels of
communication with Beijing and that that
is critical to the relationship in a
time where our increased competition we
want to make sure that doesn't Veer into
conflict and so have those multiple
layers of communication to avoid any
sort of miscalculations misperceptions
tension manage manage the tensions in a
responsible way
Parts throughout these discussion
channels to ask them particularly to to
take any particular action in the
context of the divisions I don't have
anything specific to read out to you on
that
that's Sebastian thank you very much do
you have anything on the slightly
mysterious conference it's a place in
Denmark on Saturday I mean I say little
mysterious because it was a it was a big
conference it was conscious all over the
world
including some of the Ukraine skeptic
ones you can call them that like India
but very little has come out of it um do
you have anything I want did come out of
it and could it lead to something uh
more concrete and visible so you're
referring to a meeting that happened
that was organized by Ukraine in
Copenhagen over the weekend and on
Saturday morning
um uh uh National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan participated in that meeting
virtually and has seen the senior
director for Europe Amanda's
participated in that meeting in person
again it was convened by Ukraine they
had a positive and productive discussion
about
um you know that about what principles
for peace could look look like and how
we could achieve a just and durable
piece in Ukraine
um and the attendees broadly agreed that
we want to see this world you know this
war end swiftly and we want to
ensure that everybody continues to
respect the fundamental principles of
the UN Charter
um and that includes the principles of
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
beyond that I don't have anything to
read out to you
um this was a meeting convened by
Ukraine and would refer to you refer you
to them for other participants and
details
Eric thank you again I have two
questions for you I would like to follow
up on Andrea's question uh there are
alarm bells are ringing in Poland and at
Baltic states because of the movement of
a Wagner group troops to Belarus and
Polish president just today called it a
relocation of Russian forces
so is it at all possible that the whole
Mutiny was just a cover for moving
Wagner's troop to Belarus and what's
your reaction to those concerns in on
the Eastern flank of NATO
so I'm not going to get into any sort of
speculation
about the situation
closely in all
that you know
rhetoric around nuclear weapons is you
know from that we've seen coming from
the Russians is highly irresponsible and
that said we've seen no change no reason
to assess that their nuclear posture has
changed and no reason to change our own
nuclear posture
um with that said we command remain
committed to the uh Collective defense
of the NATO alliance which of course
includes uh which of course includes
Poland and we are going to stay in close
touch with our partners and allies to
make sure we continue to monitor this
closely and responsibly
on nuclear weapons president lukashenko
said today that a significant part of
the nuclear weapons have been brought to
Belarus can you confirm that and that in
fact it happened and if true why the U.S
is not changing its nuclear posture
in response to Russia's Russian change
in nuclear their nuclear posture
John yesterday sounded like that would
be dismissive about this this movement
yeah I I can't confirm that for you
Mike
um you've talked a lot today on back on
the economy about what the president has
already done in the last two and a half
years that of course a lot of the
president's agenda was left on the table
um
child care
ending Trump tax cuts that kind of thing
at what point obviously it's not this
speech but but at what point does the
president have to Pivot to be talking
about specific proposals for new things
that he wants to do in a potential
second term or even in the latter part
of of this term and and and and and why
isn't you know if this I think Korean
yesterday called it a Cornerstone speech
or something like that why not use this
opportunity you're obviously building up
the speech to do some of that to talk a
little bit about new specific reports
well what part of what we're doing right
now is implementing so much of this
legislation right I mean if you right
now I mean we launched a couple of weeks
ago at invest.gov where you can go and
you can actually see where all the
private investment that's coming into
the United States
um where all these 35 000 Transportation
projects are springing up around across
the country that is now underway and
we're focused on implementing uh the
incredible pieces of historic
legislation this president has gotten
done over the last two and a half years
and making the case that this is the
kind of strategy we need to continue to
put the you know put the pedal to the
metal on so that we can continue this
economic progress and not risk
undercutting all of that because as
we've seen House Republicans continue to
try to repeal the IRA and the progress
that we're making and investing in clean
energy and Manufacturing restoring jobs
in America they're continuing to push
for uh unpaid for extensions of the
Trump tax cuts which would add 3 billion
dollars to our deficit send jobs
overseas and undercut the progress that
we've made so this President is laser
focused on you know the historic
progress that we've made the historic
legislation we've made over the last two
and a half years and making sure that we
Implement that right now successfully so
that we can continue to keep our foot on
the gas as I said does this
Administration think that's enough or at
some point
does the administration think he has to
lay out his his next vision
well today we're focused on tomorrow and
laying out bionomics and and talking to
the American people about uh what that
is how it's taken shape and how it's
made a meaningful impact in their lives
that's what we're focused on for the for
the moment I don't have anything to
preview for you in the way of future
economic announcements but um look we
believe there's really substantial
progress to be proud of here 13 million
jobs 12 million new small business
starts wages that are rising now as to
where they were at the beginning of this
this Administration their weight wages
are rising now even when adjusted for
inflation
there are a lot of reasons to see
positive signs in this economy as a
result of what the president has done
and we want to keep that going
all right go ahead Jerry thank you so on
speech tomorrow is bionomics kind of
like the message here that as it relates
to inflation as it relates to a lot of
the the issues that you guys were
dealing with over the last few years
that the worst of it's over is that what
we're going to hear from President Biden
I am definitely not a a a a you know
economic forecaster I'm not going to get
out my crystal ball I think as you've
heard lail just lay out really clearly
however we've seen a lot of positive
signs about inflation moderating
inflation coming down by 50 over the
last year declining for 11 months
straight certainly when you look at
where other major economies in the world
are the United States has a lower rate
of inflation right now than any other
major economy and so that tells us that
we are on the right track here and we've
got to continue to keep our foot on the
gas the administration share the
Baseline view of the Federal Reserve the
two percent inflation is the goal I as
you know cannot comment on the uh the
independent monetary policy set forward
by the Federal Reserve so I'm just going
to leave that there Ed go ahead so the
Federal Reserve says inflation is double
what the Federal Reserve would like to
see and they believe the unemployment
rate will go to 4.1 percent so how is
bidenomics not an era of high inflation
and Rising unemployment rate well take a
look at where we started and where we
are now
that's the easiest answer to your
question uh when we came into office
with the global economic headwinds of of
covid that were then compounded by
um the disruptions we faced when Russia
invaded Ukraine and disrupted Global uh
food supply chains Global fuel supply
chains sent inflation soaring around the
world right now the United States is in
a better position on inflation than any
other major economy and why is that it's
because the president took a number of
Swift and decisive actions to make sure
that we got our economy on track that we
got ourselves
open and chugging along again and today
as a consequence of that we see record
low unemployment record new small
business starts inflation that again is
lower than any other major economy in
the world and we're we're making
progress what we're seeing specifically
talking about the Auto industry for
example Ford is saying they're laying
off workers to afford the cost of the
transition to EV uh the first quarter of
this year Ford lost 700 million dollars
on their EV program lost 600 million
last year so is that what we can expect
I would just say looking across the
economy broadly we're seeing signs of
progress we're seeing as I said just a
moment ago record low unemployment
records small business starts jobs that
are coming back by the hundreds of
thousands overseas as a result of
private investment in clean energy
Manufacturing in our country and so
certainly we believe that broadly we are
on the right track here that dynomics is
having a tremendous impact and we want
to continue to see that progress move
forward
go ahead does the whiteness have a
response to Ron desantis's proposal to
use lethal Force against drug cartels
trying to cut through the border wall
along the southern border
I've got to be really careful here and
talking about uh 2024 declared 2024
presidential candidates as a result of
something that you all know it's called
the hijack prevents me from doing so but
what I will say broadly is that with
respect to
um with respect to immigration you know
this president
came into office introducing a
comprehensive immigration reform
sought and received and was able to
obtain record border security funding
was able to put in set and put in place
a series of policies that expanded legal
Pathways for migration that dealt with
our border situation and has now
resulted in a significant decrease in
unlawful border crossings since the
lifting of title 42 and he's done all of
that without the help of Republican
Governors around the country or
republican lawmakers in Congress and so
we think that this is a serious issue
that demands leadership and that you
know the president is providing that
leadership and we just hope that you
know Republicans will find their way to
the table on the policy itself do you
think putting aside Ron desantis's
proposal of it do you consider that the
use of lethal Force against you know he
says drug cartels if you consider that
Draconian I haven't seen the details of
this policy and I'm not
to it specifically
also get
me to take it and come back to you if I
can say anything about it Jackie go
ahead
what message is the president trying to
send to the American people when he
invites his son to the state dinner and
Camp David as we saw this past weekend
amid everything he's going through
every president of the United States has
invited their family to State dinner
this President also has a family he is
no different and beyond that I'm just
not going to engage on this
former Professor secretary janzaki
acknowledged that optically that might
not have been easier for the White House
um can you elaborate on on that at all
the decision to to invite the
president's son amid everything that
he's going through and what challenges
that poses uh for for this White House
to explain
like every other Administration like
every other president this president has
a family and he did exactly what many
prior administrations have done and
beyond that I really don't have any
comment on this
go ahead Catherine thanks um you've
mentioned a couple times the idea that
people are just starting to feel the
impact of the president's economic
policies does the administration have an
assessment of how long it will take for
these policies to sink in and will it be
before the next election
that will look I'm not going to speak to
Future elections from here but this
President is um as I said uh we have
already seen the strongest and fastest
economic recovery of any major economy
in the world so uh we've already seen
um I just talked about the millions of
jobs that have been created the millions
of new small business starts so we are
on on track we are making progress um
all I'm saying is that the president is
really laser focused on making sure that
we Implement his best in America agenda
and continue to uh you know as I said
except keep make sure that we keep
accelerating forward
once more on the layoffs forward I don't
know if you have any comment on the
layoffs themselves and is the
administration comfortable with the idea
that
jobs could be lost in this process of
transitioning to electric vehicles look
um certainly anytime somebody loses a
job loses a paycheck that's something
we're concerned about the president
knows that uh
deeply and personally what that is like
for a family and so certainly anytime
we're hearing about layoffs in the
economy we're concerned about that and
monitoring that and looking at that but
what I will say more broadly is part of
the reason why the the
clean energy Investments that the
president has made in our economy are so
important is because we are
simultaneously moving his ambitious
climate agenda forward but also bringing
clean energy jobs and manufacturing jobs
and Supply chains back to the United
States by the hundreds of thousands so
you know again anytime we hear that
somebody has lost a job and a paycheck
that is something we take very seriously
and don't want to diminish but we're
making progress here and we think that's
important to lift up too
Courtney
on Child Care the Commerce department is
requiring certain recipients of chips
funding to provide child care to their
workers I know you've been talking about
different infrastructure Investments
today Lyle was talking about that as
well
um looking at I know the white hog is
also looking at other ways to replicate
that you had to expand child care when
it wasn't put in the inflation reduction
act can you talk about where you are on
that in terms of attaching legislation
and child care legislation you already
have passed
I I'm gonna have to take that I just
don't have an update
um for you today on that
go ahead
you've got a quick question
about the lunch uh President Obama
reportedly told President Biden ahead of
2020 quote you don't have to do this
show you really don't can you say a
similar message from Cher today
I can and I don't know what you're
referring to
regarding whether he should continue to
serve in public life I I don't know what
you're referring to and I don't have any
comment on it it's on last week does the
White House believe attorney general
Garland committed perjury when he
testified under that Delaware U.S
attorney David Weiss could bring charges
outside of his district I don't have any
comment on this Anita go ahead in 10
days
I have a China question and also
um a Ukraine question first of all on
China can you just lay out the
expectations for secretary Ellen's trip
and is this possible executive order on
outbound investment on the table
um I'll leave it to the treasury
Department to discuss any potential
travel that secretary Yellen has great
then on Ukraine today's package I didn't
see it mention uh long range missiles
which Ukraine has asked for uh they want
them to take back territory are those
not on the table why are they not there
and are they going to be considered in
future packages so our Focus has always
been on making sure that Ukraine has
what it needs to defend itself and
defend its territory and its sovereignty
um what I would just say to you on your
specific question is um you know you
should feel free to reach out to the
department Department of Defense about
all of the specific contents of this
package I think they may have some more
detail to lay out
perfect
thank you the Supreme Court decision
today on Moore versus Harper
sure
um so uh this morning at the Supreme
Court there was a critical decision with
respect to voting rights as you know
this has been an enormous priority for
the president and the vice president
since the day that they entered office
to strengthen ensure up voting rights in
this country and so we're pleased that
the Supreme Court rejected the extreme
legal Theory presented in this case
which would have interfered with state
governments which would have opened the
door for politicians to undermine the
will of the people and would have
threatened the freedom of all Americans
to have their voices heard at The Ballot
Box
again as you've just heard me say the
president and the vice president have
made this a significant priority since
they first entered office and they will
continue to fight to make sure that to
fight to urge Congress to pass a
critical voting rights legislation in
Congress to as we go forward to ensure
there are fair Congressional maps and
that people have access to The Ballot
Box
inflation real quickly please so you
mentioned that the White House believes
inflation is moderating the Bank of
America CEO Brian Monahan said in an
interview today that we think it'll take
Federal officials all of this year and
all of next year into 2025 before they
get inflation in line with their
long-term Target does the White House
agree with this assessment I certainly
am not going to make any predictions
from your economic forecast from here
all I can say is what Lil said a few
moments ago which is that we've seen
inflation come down significantly over
the past year 50 of the last year 11
months straight and you know we're going
to continue to do everything in our
power to keep lowering costs for the
American people and continue making all
that progress
following up on the president's call
with President zielinski he said that
there would be a second one so it sounds
like that hasn't happened yet though do
you expect that I don't today call to
read out to you okay and then in the
call that they did have did the
president encourage president zielinski
to attend the NATO Summit next month in
Lithuania and does President Biden
expect to meet with president zolenski
in person at that Summit I don't have
any news to share with you on that front
certainly this is going to be a really
important NATO Summit with a lot on the
table an opportunity for the president
and other NATO allies to gather and talk
about so many things including Ukraine
um you know as we've said many times you
know one thing that is quite remarkable
today is how
NATO is stronger it's larger it's more
purposeful than ever before of course
we're looking forward to welcoming our
newest member in the NATO alliance
Finland in a couple of weeks and
certainly this is going to be a
important Summit on a number of fronts
but I don't have anything respect
respective to a particular bilateral
meeting to read out to you today
uh let's just do one we have one more
go right here thank you
um the Russian defense minister is in
Cuba today he's meeting there with his
counterpart and they've also agreed to
strengthen the relationship invest in
military projects is the White House
watching this do you have anything on
this uh this is not something I I need
to take this one back and see what my
Nancy colleagues might have to say about
it all right thanks all have a great
afternoon and I'll see some of you
in Chicago tomorrow